bonjour la déclaration universelle des
droits de l'homme particulièrement
l'article 3 consacre trois droits le
droit à la vie le droit à la sécurité
mais aussi vraiment la sûreté que chaque
citoyen a le droit à la vie privée a le
droit de vivre libres mais aussi d'être
dans sa sécurité et d'être de vivre
vraiment en sécurité d'avant tous ici vu
dans les nouvelles actualités des crises
qui ont frappé des territoires lointains
parfois saint martin irma maria harvey
qui ont tant qu'ouragan durement frappé
la caraïbe c'est au radon nous ont un
peu fait oublier que cet été des
dizaines de milliers de provençaux de
corse ont dû quitter leur maison
plus de 2200 30 feux de forêt de plus
d'un hectare dans le sud de la france
étaient derniers sont plus de 200
kilomètres carrés qui sont partis en
fumée et en une nuit plus de 12000
varois qui ont dû quitter leurs maisons
alors dans un monde ultra connectés où
on nous parle énormément de big data de
data les d'open data d'intelligence
artificielle au service de l'humanité
comment peut-on encore aujourd'hui dans
les villes françaises sur des
territoires français avoir des
populations isolées sans moyen de
communication pendant plusieurs heures
voire plusieurs jours
est ce que certains d'entre vous dans la
salle habite paris qui habite paris
très bien
ceux qui habitent paris lesquels d'entre
vous connaissent les itinéraires
d'évacuation de paris pas grand monde en
personne qui connaît les abris ou les
établissements qui reçoivent le public
en cas de crise voilà toujours personne
pourtant on a vécu en 2016 puis en 2018
une inondation qui a frappé un peu paris
un peu quand même eu des morts en 2016
énormément de dégâts matériels
tout paris et la région francilienne a
retenu son souffle face à l'inondation
que nous avons connus de la scène est
pourtant encore aujourd'hui en tant que
parisien
vous ne savez toujours pas comment
évacuer paris ont pas trop se focaliser
sur l'inondation en elle-même mois se
focaliser sur le sujet de cette
conférence
la smart city la ville intelligente on
nous on parle beaucoup et en théorie
grâce à tous les moyens de communication
dont nous disposons certains d'entre
vous sont en train d'utiliser leur
téléphone mobile pour des réseaux
sociaux communiqué nous sommes ultra
connectés en trente sociétés modernes
nous devrions être aujourd'hui en pleine
transition vers cette fameuse ville
intelligente l'innovation en elle même
c'est une chose une coupure
d'électricité à paris c'en est une autre
et face à cette inondation qui nous a
frappés très récemment à paris nous
aurions pu connaître un black out
électrique qui aurait misé à mal les
réseaux de communication qui ont été un
peu partiellement demain j'ai d'ailleurs
pendant cette inondation faut savoir
qu'un réseau téléphonique normal ne peut
douter que 10% de ses clients maximum
quand vous avez une inondation certaines
armoires électriques et téléphoniques
sont inondées dans l'opérateur les
opérateurs vont perdre un peu de leur
capacité donc un parisien peut très vite
se retrouver dans une situation très
inconfortable sans moyen de
communication
comment vous prévenir comment avant
voir des nouvelles de vos proches de vos
enfants de vos parents comment avoir de
l'eau parfois puisque les pompes qui
vous abreuve robinet chez vous sont
électriques et pas d'électricité pas
d'eau pas de nourriture pas
télécommunications aucun parisien peut
très vite se retrouver dans une
situation très inconfortable
et c'est exactement à cet endroit que je
vais vous emmener
vous imaginez que vous n'avez plus
d'électricité plus de moyens de
communication plus d'eau
vous devrez très rapidement quitter
votre logement même si vous n'êtes pas
inondée et c'est là que cette smart city
dont tout le monde rêve hyperconnecté
qui nous permet de nous transporter très
vite d'avoir le meilleur moyen de
transport les meilleurs moyens de
communication les meilleures moyennes
formation devient vite une chimère alors
lorsqu'on vient plus réfléchi comment
vous faites si jamais il ya plus de
communication plus de réseau
téléphonique
il ya plus de 200 ans la france a connu
un peu moins que ça en 1902 la france a
connu sa plus grande catastrophe
naturelle plus de 30000 français sont
décédés
oui les vifs sur les flancs de la
montagne pelée en martinique
c'était la première fois qu'on utilisait
la radio en situation de crise les caps
télégraphique à l'époque qui traversait
déjà l'atlantique ont été rompues par
l'éruption de la montagne pelée et sait
capter les graphiques d'un routeur les
télégrammes et donc on était sans
nouvelles de la martinique
puisque c'est capté les graphiques
malheureusement était coupée on envoie
alors à ce moment-là du staff yaye en
1902 pour pouvoir déployer des émetteurs
radio qui permettait de relier la
martinique à la guadeloupe est derrière
avec les capter des graphiques de la
guadeloupe à l'hexagone mais avoir des
nouvelles de la martinique saint pierre
a été rayée des communes de france
pendant près de dix ans la commune a été
complètement rayé de la carte
c'est le premier usage la radio en temps
de crise et c'est radieux quand elles
sont revenues à paris ont été installés
sur la tour eiffel
on commence à voir les prémices de la
smart
si de la ville intelligente déjà en 1902
puisque cette tour eiffel est devenu un
moyen de synchroniser des horloges le
temps extrêmement important car il
permet de synchroniser les
communications téléphoniques les
longitudes avoir des horloges
synchronisée a permis de calculer les
longitudes des bateaux du ca faye et
devient le patron des longitudes et en
1909 quand il a fallu démonter ses
antennes radio sur la tour eiffel
on ne l'a pas fait pourquoi parce que
paris était devenu grâce à ces imitant
radio une ville intelligente une ville
qui grâce à la radio permettait d'avoir
la position des bateaux et la tour
eiffel encore présente aujourd'hui est
un émetteur radio
c'est un des piliers de l'intelligence
de paris qui permet d'avoir la
télévision numérique aujourd'hui la
radio des réseaux téléphoniques
cellulaire est devenu patron des
longitudes du ca faye a continué ses
travaux et quelques générations plus
tard on a lancé des satellites qui sont
devenus des horloges en orbite a enfin
été d'abord la constellation gps par les
américains glonass les russes les
européens avec galileo
les chinois baidu les japonais qui
cédait 16 bref tous ces systèmes radio
permettent aujourd'hui de rendre toutes
les villes intelligentes sans ses
satellites
sans ces horloges au dessus de nos têtes
pas d'intelligence pas de réseau de
télécommunications pas de
synchronisation des flux financiers
ce qui m'intéresse aujourd'hui c'est de
vous montrer à quel point toutes ces
technologies ne valent rien si des
hommes des femmes ne se mobilisent pas
pour les déployer pour les exploiter car
si vous revenez à mon anecdote de tout à
l'heure sur la scène
que serait paris ville intelligente
sensée citoyens intelligents ce qui fait
l'intelligence de paris c'est notre
intelligence
si notre capacité à nous organiser à
nous réorganiser face à une coupure
électrique à une coupure d'un réseau de
télécommunication et pour revenir à ces
fameux 200 ans de flashbacks auquel je
vous invitais il ya plus de 200 ans
marconi ampère
volta test la curie tous ces grands
hommes toutes ces grandes femmes cadres
et pardon patrick lamarre et dit la
marque pas le même hedy lamarr grandes
radios matrix va toutes ces personnes
ont travaillé le radioamateurisme alors
le radioamateurisme pour ceux qui ne
savent pas trop ce que c'est ses loisirs
technique et dit lamar grande femme
actrice qui a joué dans sa mission et
dalila j'invite à tout le monde connaît
un peu son visage mais beaucoup moins
son oeuvre dans l'innovation et dans
l'intelligence de développement de
l'intelligence et vit à travailler sur
le radar travailler sur le wifi que vous
utilisez
certainement en ce moment les travaux de
cette femme ont permis de détecter des
avions alors adam m et nous permettent
aujourd'hui dans nos mains d'avoir des
terminaux qui nous permettent pas d'être
connectés les uns aux autres 2 pourquoi
pas recevoir des instructions
d'évacuation et c'est cette intelligence
collectif que les radioamateurs au
travers leurs loisirs technique diffuse
un radio amateur c'est quelqu'un qui va
disposer d'une licence d'un état et qui
va lui permettre à la fois d'émettre et
de recevoir des messages radio dans
différents modes alors ça peut être de
la phonie donc de la voix comme je vous
parle en ce moment à travers ce micro
connectés en radio à la régie ça peut
être aussi des réseaux de données
donc comme ce que vous utiliser au
quotidien je suis le wifi le bluetooth
ça peut être des systèmes de balises or
des balises maritimes aériennes voire
spatiale qui dizaines de satellites raj
amateurs ont été lancés et ses moyens
radio amateur permettent en cas de crise
de disposer de trois piliers le premier
pilier du raj amateurisme c'est la
fraternité et c'est ce qui rend nos
territoires
intelligent la solidarité la fraternité
les villages à sendai où il y a eu le
plus le plus fort tout survie ce sont
les villages où les voisins étaient
solidaires où ils ont été frappés les
ans aux portes des autres voire as tu
entendu la sirène
as tu entendu le signal qui dit qu'il
faut évacuer deuxième pilier du
raj amateurisme la gestion de crise non
je suis en train de vous parler
aujourd'hui et l'expérimentation
cette expérimentation qui peut mais sans
cesse de repousser les limites de
l'intelligence collective
cette expérimentation de la naissance en
97 à une norme qui s'appelle l' alerte
cellulaire le cell broadcast en anglais
ce protocole est né dans le sud de la
france au sein de l'aide si le protocole
alerte cellulaire ou cell broadcast
permet de recevoir sur un téléphone
mobile un message alerte
s'il y avait quelque chose de grave qui
se passait dehors
en théorie normalement nous devrions
être prévenus par des sirènes je ne suis
pas certain qu'on l'entendrait cette
sirène ici je ne suis pas certain que si
vous l'entendiez vous sauriez prendre la
bonne décision et ses travaux collectifs
ces travaux d'intelligence collective
permettent aujourd'hui de travailler sur
cette aventure il en est de prouver que
ça fonctionne c'est un peu mon travail
aujourd'hui au sein de l'eau angie que
j'écris qui s'appelle hand pour hacker
the games natural disasters qui fédère
des radioamateurs des community managers
des développeurs des hackers qui met à
disposition de tous du logiciel libre un
terreau du maté à libre des compétences
scientifiques et techniques je reviens
de la guadeloupe pour le 15 mars on a
participé 26 qui s'appelle karim wade
qui est un des plus gros exercice
d'évacuation de population plus de
800000 personnes jouent leur propre rôle
de citoyen évacuent leurs bureaux
évacuent leurs maisons évacuent leur
ville leur village pour être prêt le
jour où ce tsunami survient à prendre la
bonne décision
le bihan moyen de rendre un territoire
intelligent le meilleur moyen de
construire une smart city une ville
intelligente c'est d'informer les
populations des risques auxquels elles
sont confrontées ensuite former ces
personnes à faire face à ce risque est
bien entendu au bout du bout quand la
lea est présent alerté ses populations
en france malheureusement nous avons un
radio amateur pour 400 habitants aux
etats unis un radio amateur pour 7000
habitants pendant aux etats-unis 1 pour
400 on pourrait se dire que
ce états unis il ya plus de crise c'est
pour ça qu'il ya plus de radio amateur
mais comme je vous le disais tout à
l'heure
paris inondations de la scène sud de la
france est corse feux de forêt
saint-martin ouragans sud de la france
tremblement de terre de temps en temps
nous sommes aussi un pays à risque et
nous avons été durement frappées par les
attentats récemment ce qui prouve que
nous avons besoin aujourd'hui de ces
solutions techniques certes mais aussi
d'organisation humaines pour faire face
à ces crises qui vont de toute façon
nous appâter de plus en plus
échauffement thématique n'est plus une
théorie je pense que les catastrophes
qui se succèdent nous le prouve
en revanche ce qui est certain c'est que
nous devrons nous adapter de plus en
plus vite à ces crises
alors que faire du coup aujourd'hui
évidemment je vous invite en tant que
radio amateur à passer vos licences et
entre six mois à un an de travail
si vous partez un cursus qui n'est pas
du tout scientifique à raison d'une
journée de travail par semaine sur les 1
méga scientifique et technique
ça prendra moins de temps c'est un
loisir technique où vous avez énormément
de personnes qui souhaitent transmettre
leurs savoirs va vous avez la
possibilité aussi d'animer ce qu'on
appelle les médias sociaux en gestion
d'urgence
utilisez vos téléphones mobiles en cas
d'exercice en cas de crise pour
évidemment relayer des messages utiles
évitez de relayer de mauvaises rumeurs
puisque les réseaux sociaux
malheureusement sur ces deux champs et
évidemment il ya les droits et droit de
dire de parler de vous exprimer vous
avez aussi des devoirs des
responsabilités de ne pas relayer
évidemment de fausses rumeurs et ses
médias sociaux en gestion durant sur
devenu une discipline avec des
associations comme vie sauf par exemple
qui ont des dizaines de volontaires en
france et dans le monde
kamel ben justement de travailler cette
discipline sur les réseaux sociaux
doivent bien route et bien transmettre
les bons messages au monde ces crises
pouvez aussi vous engager dans les
forces de sécurité civile allez dans les
casernes les plus proches de chez vous
on a un gros déficit de sapeurs-pompiers
et je pense qu'ils seront ravis de vous
recevoir que le souhaitent faire au sein
de cette ong ondes ce moment à la fois
ou sensibilisées sur ces questions vous
montrer à quel point on peut être très
vite vulnérables la fée électricité nous
a rendus
extrêmement dépendant du confort mais
nous avons aujourd'hui tous les outils
pour rendre notre territoire intelligent
mon invitation donc aujourd'hui c'est de
rejoindre nos rangs de travailler sur
ces réseaux sociaux ils sont utiles ils
sont pertinents et crée enfin un vrai
corps de sécurité civile numérique merci
à vous
[Applaudissements]